all right listen up y'all
i'm your substitute teacher mr garvey
i taught school for 20 years in the
inner city
so don't even think about messing with
me
y'all feel me
mm-hmm okay let's take roll here
jay quality
where's jay quillin at
no jay quellon here
yeah
uh do you mean jacqueline
okay
so that's how it's gonna be
y'all want to play
okay then
i've got my eye on you jake welling
balake
where is belake at
no no belake here today
yes sir
my name is blake
are you out of your goddamn mind
blake
what
do you want to go to war malaki no cause
we could go to war no i'm for real
i'm for real
so you better check yourself
d nice
is there a d nice
if one of y'all
says some silly ass name
this whole class is gonna fill my wrath
now d nice
do you mean denise son of a [ __ ]
you say your name right right now denise
say right denise correctly denise right
denise right
nice that's better thank you
now
a-a-ron
where are you
where is a-a-ron right now
no a-a-ron huh
well you better be sick
dead or mute a-a-ron yeah oh man
why didn't you answer me the first time
i said it huh huh i'm just you know i'm
just asking you i said it like four
times so why didn't you say it the first
time i said a-a-ron
because it's pronounced aaron son of bob
you done messed up a.a ron now take your
ass on down to osak hennessy's office
right now and tell him exactly what you
did
who oh shaq hennessy
principal o'shaughnessy get out of my
goddamn classroom before i break my foot
off in your ass insubordinate
and churlish
timothy
present
thank you
i'm gonna take a little roll here
jay cuellar
here
you are present
blocky
right here uh-huh
d-nice here
good jessica
thank you
mr garvey
what is a.a ron some of us need to leave
uh a few minutes early today
oh
oh is that so mm-hmm
and what
pray tell
is the reason
for this premature exodus
your book
photos um
we have to leave 15 minutes early to
meet up with our clubs
all right you know what that might work
with other substitute teachers but i
taught in the inner city for over 20
years now y'all
want to leave my class early so y'all
can go meet up at the club
ain't none of y'all old enough to go to
the damn club
ridiculous
mr garvey god son of a [ __ ]
did us
doctor just then yes
i'm gonna throw you out the goddamn
window
what jay quinlan mr garvey we're telling
the truth we we have clubs at this
school we have clubs for special
interests okay i see so y'all want to
play y'all wanna play yeah okay we're
gonna play little games fine i'll play
i'm more than happy to play some games
with y'all anyone who's in a club
stand your ass up
uh-huh oh yeah there it is there it is
the usual suspects what the hell club
are you in jaquelin
future leaders of america
okay okay
how would you know
if you're gonna be a leader
in the future is there a stargate
in your bedroom can you travel through
town jay kweller no just sit the flip
down
but like i don't here's the thing i
don't even know why i'm about to ask you
this
but lockheed
what club are you in i'm part of the
spanish club
sp this
you about as spanish as rion seacrest
with your big-ass fraggle rock hare
how about you d nice i'm in the chess
club
uh i'm sorry sweetheart you are
not in the chest
the mosquito bite club maybe oh it's
hurtful
truthful
there he is
hey ron hey
what club
are you in
i'm the president of the glee club why
do i talk the glee club
like they gonna have a club dedicated to
a tv show take your ass to osha
hennessy's office right now before i
bust a club up in your butt okay
no okay here you go
mischievous and deceitful chicanerous
and deplorable
this is principal o'shaughnessy students
please report to the gymnasium for your
club photos fake announcement
now does anybody in here
have a valid reason for leaving this
classroom timothy i got to go pick up my
daughter you're excused